[Musik]
hallo herr zu fahren
heute gibt es ein leckeres mittagessen
oder abendessen je nachdem wann ihres
zubereitet ich mache heute eine kiste
murat denkt wahrscheinlich nicht schon
wieder eine quiche aber ich liebe dich
für alle ist es mir ganz anderes und
zwar habe ich hier einen riss im boden
das heißt ich habe ja auch nicht einen
mürbeteig der manchmal auf dem schwer zu
schmecken häppchen im rössli boden aus
kartoffeln und in der mitte habe ich
eine füllung aus spinat und schafkäse
und tomaten
das ganze schmeckt wirklich super lecker
man kann super vorbereiten tanz warm
oder auch keins essen und daher liebe
ich gehe schon allen variationen
er kann das ganz vegetarisch machen so
wie ich oder ihr könnt zum beispiel
stutthof oder oft weg mit drei machen wo
wir uns eben gerne mit sie zeigt jetzt
einfach mal kurz die zutaten für den
rest boden brauch ich 750 gramm
geschalteter doppeln dass sie nicht mehr
kochende ein einsatz käme noch die
gewürze eine telefon und halben
teelöffel chili und rhythmus etwas
pfeffer und muskatnuss und für die
füllung brauche ich einen esslöffel
olivenöl eine zwiebel an den juden
charlotte knobloch sehen 200 schafe
zweier raimund kamm cocktailtomaten 100
milliliter milch und 800 gramm gefahren
und bin zuerst der was die boden dran
und dafür den kartoffeln und äpfel
reiben ich nehme hier eine große reibe
und macht eine küchenmaschine aber
bekommt auch eine ganz normale bücherei
befördern
[Musik]
sobald die kartoffeln fertig sind geht
auf ein sauberes geschirrtuch und werden
bis in die plötzlichkeit ausdrückt und
damit einfach droht jetzt nicht sinn
macht wird dadurch werden es auch ein
bisschen klüger macht es einfach so für
einwickeln entdeckt werden und dann guck
mal ich freue mich die fed raus drücken
[Musik]
die kartoffeln in eine große schale und
jetzt kann ich sie mit den restlichen
zutaten vermischen bei salz pfeffer und
die gewürze und das muss
[Musik]
ich glaube ich eine frau mit hebe boden
der drei bis zehn meter im durchmesser
und die gespräche sorgfältig mit butt
krems trail hebe wurden deswegen weil
man später dann wie viel fleiß
herausbekommt und durch die befüllung
kleinere löcher in der backform witz die
tat oder die türken sind verschickt
jetzt drücke ich diese rusty mache hier
ein
auch ein bisschen am rand entlang
gedrückt
und so kommt es in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
für unsere einflussreichste früher etwa
25 minuten so kann er was die wurden zu
machen und zu werden
[Musik]
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen habe ich
jetzt schon freien geworfen
die kommunizieren und wenn jetzt zwei
bis drei minuten glasig angebraten und
der zwischenzeit kann ich auch schon mal
die tomaten halbieren
[Musik]
die eierbecher mit der milch und die
bauernschaft leistung ein
mit sonder spinat zu den zwiebeln dazu
natürlich ist ein bisschen feuchtigkeit
und es ist auch gut so des hauses den
verkauf und jetzt raten wir sind so
lange diese flüssigkeit verdunstet
[Musik]
hier wird sich jetzt mit imbiss ins eis
und pfeffer salz deswegen nur beim
training auch schafskäse oder einfach
nicht übersetzt werden und dass spinat
kommt rein in die hose
gut verrühren die tomaten habe ich auch
schon herbert geht vom jetzt hier auch
mit sein
jetzt kommt die füllung auf dem boden
wird schon glatt gestrichen und diese
später noch mal 45 minuten backen
[Musik]
die käse wird gebacken und habt ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen so bekomme ich
ja auch leichter aus der form heraus
jetzt nimmt die einfach ein kleines
schäden sind zum beispiel stellt es hier
drauf und löst ganz groß ist es jetzt
den rand
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich nicht angeschnitten
werden ich muss dazu sagen ihr wisst ja
meine problematisch zu hause mit meinem
backofen die unter hitze die
funktioniert einfach nicht so wie sie
soll das heißt die autoprüfung bisschen
farbe vertragen aber ich wollte es
einfach nicht noch länger verlassen
[Musik]
die
so lecker richtig schön 40 und ihr könnt
hier bei dem rezept übrigens auch
frischen spinat verwenden oder auch
mangold wird oft sehr gut dazu passen
ich nehme gerne china noch in tiefenbach
denn wer wird nach der ernte sofort
schockgefrostet und da sind einfach die
ganzen vitamine noch entfalten und
außerdem auf vorrat dieses kraftvolle
stück probiere ich jetzt nichts mehr mit
hatte gestern schon die teams und haften
mit meinen freunden gegessen und sind
wirklich so verletzt
außerdem ist kein spiel auf den zähnen
haben manche noch weiter reden falls
jetzt auch lust darauf bekommen habe und
gerne manchmal redet mein mund und mein
gegen schaltet sich erst mal wichtig
falls jetzt auch noch bekommen habt auch
diese leckere kiefern geht auch wenn ich
mir das nochmal alles gelaufen und ich
bin schon ganz viel spaß beim machen wir
sind links mal wieder was dann zu gucken
fertig
[Musik]